oh look at that it's about me and um
it's it's in the space of you know Alex
Jones but we have this tweet from Elijah
Shafer it's a clip from his show where
Kanye disses me and uh okay I'll just
play it for you guys here you go you
ready the temple is the MPC you know and
you're a real a real human being so no
one's ever heard of uh Tim fool you know
you're the legend that is Alex Jones and
you were fighting on the front line and
now we're here with you you got some
other Superheroes part of the avenger
movie fighting for Christ so apparently
he said that I don't know that's what I
was told uh he I got a phone call 10
minutes before the show and I was told
what to say yeah you got contacted
before the show like right before this
like literally those are the words right
before he says actually he's an NPC the
hour before the show we are sitting in
this room right hanging out talking as
the cameras are being adjusted uh surges
is getting things ready people are
grabbing drinks so it just literally
didn't happen but I got a beef you can
call me an NPC and say nobody's heard of
me I'm I defer to Alex Jones I mean that
guy's been around he was he was doing
this work 10 years before I even heard
of you know a phone before I even got
anywhere near doing this kind of stuff
well Tim you're a true populist when you
know when when you're Kanye West you're
saying you know quote-unquote Hitler
wasn't that bad of a guy that's not very
exactly a populist opinion so today
you know you are an NPC no offense but
you're not and uh but I can see why
that's why he's calling you that do you
understand but I I wonder like
like why he came here you know what I
mean I think maybe maybe Milo was like
No it's it's a good show it's it's it's
it's you know they get like a million
something views with their Clips or
something like that I don't know he has
a little bit of a media blackout from
what I understand from what happened
with what he said on Tucker and all that
stuff you know yeah I do believe a lot
of media companies right now will not
platform them so you're one of the few
ones and the big you're the biggest
Independent Media broadcaster you and
then Infowars right there I mean daily
wire had him on Boom Candace is canceled
he can't go back on there Blaze we
haven't had him on so and Kanye and I
say this you can come on my show my
Show's coming out very soon and the
blaze is going to be mad that I said
that but Kanye is welcome on my show
I'll jump on a blimp let's go Kanye all
day and I'm gonna be nice to you I'll
let you guys in on some uh internal
stuff uh when we were originally trying
to book their accommodation for the
night the hotel uh wouldn't let us do it
we don't know exactly what happened wait
you said it's for Kanye West why not
just say like uh you have to do credit
card authorization so when you book a
hotel this is the most annoying thing
about traveling anybody who travels for
work knows exactly what this is your
company will book your hotel and you'll
show up and they'll say and you have a
credit card on fi and you're like my
company booked it with the company card
place it sucks right yes and so what we
have to do is we have to call in and
confirm our card details for the room
and as soon as we said who would be
checking like when you're when you're
booking a room you got to put their name
on it how else do they show up and give
you the name and then then they're just
like we'll get back to you and put us on
hold and then it was like an hour later
of like hold on we're talking to the
manager and then we're like okay this is
not working we're just sitting on the
phone so we canceled it we got an Airbnb
I wonder if uh
there's there's some other stuff I want
to respect their privacy to a certain
degree but uh even when it came to other
travel details there were like you know
he's getting his accounts locked he's
saying that they're coming after himself
like that and then that happened and we
don't we don't think too much about it
but I'm wondering if that's a component
I guess he was able to get a private
plane you know so he's still able to do
something so I don't get it I don't know
man
no idea but uh the one thing I do wonder
is
you know when he came here
I'm getting attacked by two different
groups
one group is saying that I shouldn't
have said a single word how dare you you
should have just let him keep talking
okay and the other side saying I didn't
push back enough I should have been not
letting him talk and push him back on by
this is crazy but Alex Jones actually
does interrupt him a couple times and
and he seems totally fine with it yeah
he keeps reminding him that it's Kanye's
show he's like he interrupts him Alex
will be like well I'm just thinking and
it's your show you're you're in the
control here but and then Alex will say
so he keeps reminding yay that it's
yay's interview you're here I'm just
throwing this in he got testy a little
bit where you saw like a lot of tension
and you clearly saw Alex Jones being
very uncomfortable in that situation and
of course he pushed back eventually but
when they're making these small clips
and they're going viral on the internet
when you're just saying yeah yeah yeah
after something someone says something
controversial that you know that's that
that everyone's sharing those videos and
now pointing fingers at AJ did they
bring like if you're going to say that
Hitler did not kill six million people
you better have the data and the facts
to back that up right there in your hand
that's such an insane like a powerful
statement to go up online without any
pushback or evidence and there was no
pushback but
I I whatever I guess I mean like I
mentioned this earlier cernovich said we
dodged a bullet I saw that said that to
Luke and Luke you were saying well we
would have debated we would have had a
conversation we probably would have been
screaming here and maybe that
conversation needed to be had I mean
maybe he needed to know about Margaret
Sanger maybe he needed to know about how
he's on team establishment by promoting
a lot of this population control
Eugenics nonsense I don't think he knows
what he's talking about a lot of the
times he was referring to Nick to answer
his questions Whenever there was even a
little bit of pushback Nick was laughing
the whole time enjoying the show and
then going on and expanding on points
that clearly yay couldn't articulate so
with that with all these people here
they would have brought up their idea we
would have smashed it down be like no we
don't agree with this because of this
and this and this and then it would have
been a conversation it would probably
would have been an argument probably
would have been screaming maybe maybe
there's a small chance that there would
have been some kind of understanding and
and I think it was still worth it in
order to have that small possibility
because that would have changed
everything I just want to mention too
that uh when yay was here he said he
didn't want to be on this show
he said that before yeah he also said he
also said we got to do his show every
single uh
that means he
didn't see the show no no no no no no no
and then but then we were we were like
maybe if this goes well we'll see what
happens
and he was like but he was like this
will go well I'm like yeah
we don't know he's an artist he's like
oh let's collab let's collab I mean I'm
just guessing that too well I'll clarify
clarify because Luke is right what he
said was something like these guys keep
trying to get me to do these podcasts
but something I'm paraphrasing he's like
there's no point me coming on this I
don't want to do it but then
you give me information like this and he
points on his notepad where he wrote
down ballot harvesting right because he
asked me downstairs in the in the
basement in the skate park he asked me
as we're walking up the stairs he was
like I want to know how to become
president how do I become president him
and it was like I just said I I don't
know Milo knows and then as we're
walking away he goes you know I asked
you how to become president you ignored
me and I said oh that was up here no no
we're walking up the stairs oh again and
then I said no I I said Milo knows I'm
I'm not I'm not I'm just a guy on the
internet man I'm a guy who complains on
the internet then we're sitting down he
said the same thing he's like you know I
asked you twice how to become president
you keep ignoring me and then I was like
okay ballot harvesting and he was like
what's what's that and I explained how
bad harvesting works and he was like
whoa and he writes it down and then he
brings up how he didn't want to be here
basically like they want him to do these
shows he doesn't want to do it but then
he gets something like that and makes it
worth it I kind of just think he didn't
want to be here yeah he didn't he was
honest he I mean he goes where he wants
does what he wants and he's like I'll
use I bet Milo was like Yay if you want
to become president Tim pulls the guy he
he has a huge Reach people trust him
he's brilliant let's go and he's like
yes I want to be president I don't I
don't think Milo said that I think
that's I think that's why they came and
why they all came together you kind of
baby Joe Rogan it's like Joe Rogan but
he's like the Rogan apology he's like a
politics guy yeah he's not I my my view
is probably that he said
this is a show that's got a decent reach
that we can go on he'll probably have us
of course that's probably he's asking me
how he can win I mean he's already
asking like an advisor like what can I
do but why would he fly six hours six
hours one way he got nothing going on
man
and then sit down here for like 20
minutes if I come out yeah like oh you
don't you don't believe everything I
gave him cookies he took some on the way
out yeah well what was that deal because
he goes this isn't going to be a Lex
Friedman deal again you know he said
that and I was like this wasn't even
like that argument over Judaism that's
what it comes down to I'm so concerned
with this argument too because it really
is important to differentiate between
the religion and the culture it's the
only religion on Earth that has a
attached Birthright bloodline to it
which is kind of weird and probably
illogical and like just because your
parents are a certain way doesn't mean
that you believe in God and but the
tenets of Judaism is that you believe in
God so like I don't want people saying
they're Jewish and then being abusive to
humans and and giving the faith a bad
name yeah hey butcher tell me Tim I
remember you left during the podcast for
a minute did you ever go out there
because I know Luke talked to him but
did you ever talk to them outside no
they're in the car oh never no when I
got up uh it was to try and figure out
what they were doing with their
accommodation and and like I was saying
like like whether you should get their
plane or whatever well I'm like yeah
well we we got him a round trip flight
and all that stuff and I'm like what are
you guys doing and they're like don't
worry we're taking care of it that's
what I was trying to figure out look I
said to him I was like I I immediately
messaged Milo like so like what's going
on and then uh because we we booked
their accommodation and stuff and then
he just said we're taking care of it
don't worry about it and I said okay and
that's what that's what I was trying to
take care of I don't want to talk on the
phone I didn't call him I was calling
the travel agency and stuff like that
and so uh I couldn't take those calls
here live you know what I mean private
details of where they're going to be and
stuff like that so and that was about it
and I told him I was like bro I'm not
even mad it is what it is yeah he owes
me nothing we we invite people to come
on because it's a benefit to us we don't
pay guests you know you being here is a
benefit to us that's that's what it is
so and Ian came in he was emotional
everybody was emotional it was really a
good episode you know it's good what I'm
saying you know it seems like it was bad
but it was I think it you know it was in
the grand scheme if you can back off and
look at it from like a 10 million foot
view you're going to look at this moment
in history of like that was the first
meeting between Temple and Kanye West
maybe maybe
um I don't I don't like celebrity
culture stuff I don't like the pr
planned stuff
I don't like the okay here's the plan
we're gonna go on a show but you need to
storm out Midway through and that's
that's Hollywood celebrity culture I
don't want to be involved in any of that
it's just yeah but that's all fake and
dumb but people love it it's just I
don't say poison you know it's like
sugar people are allowed to have that
stuff they're allowed to like that stuff
there's so many there's so many YouTube
channels that love drama that uh you
know they they want to find anything
they can about anybody it's like what
The Young Turks turned into like
political WWE and that's and that's kind
of insulting a WWE because we know that
they're having fun yeah but like turning
the political space into uh
you like a stage crap show yeah just
like it's like it's like this is this is
something that I just don't like about
YouTube is my advice to all these
YouTubers who want to do shows is just
don't talk about each other don't talk
about personal stuff talk about bigger
issue things like you know how people's
lives are being impacted by policy how
politicians are are either lying or
telling truth what you know what is in
control of their lives or in control of
their minds what is affecting them Fair
Point that commentators do have an
influence Joe Rogan says something and
it becomes news because so influential I
totally understand that but there's
there's so much of like watching the
social space devolve and probably the
saddest example is The Young Turks how
it's like jenk and Anna just screaming
at me like they're not making any
arguments they're just calling me a
loser a [ __ ] Jank is doing this weird
chicken thing where he goes back and
forth and I'm I'm not trying to drag
them by saying this I'm trying to you
know I don't like talking about them
because I don't think they're relevant
but they do exemplify how the space is
is turning into uh into into this like
celebrity you know I don't like it I
don't want to be involved it's like
Jerry Springer but uh more degenerate
and low IQ I bet today uh sbf's like yes
yes yes
I mean he's already on a big PR media
tour with the with the corporate media
glorifying him but I just wish I mean a
lot of this is drama a lot of those a
lot of this is just like you girl kind
of stuff between between dudes I I just
wish we would talk about Jeffrey Epstein
as much as we do Kanye West if we if the
media would just be focused on where
Jeffrey Epstein was going who he was
meeting with what he was saying like
they are but Kanye the world would be a
better place if just FB SBF would get as
much attention as Nick Fuentes my
goodness please please we could only
dream Sam bankman freed is his name yeah
well well just not not just Sam but also
you have to remember you have to look
into Jimmy Seville too and that's why
you know I think that's so important
because that gives you the context if
you're like wow there's people this
powerful and this guy was knighted by
the queen and he was literally probably
the worst cereal child rapist of all
time as a matter of fact not just that
he did even worse stuff that we can't
mention on this show yeah
it's absolutely like the most like
Monsters Beyond even understanding for
most human beings sorry go ahead and so
when you realize that there are people
that are at the highest upper echelon of
society that are actually doing terrible
stuff to children and you see the you
know timely Bill Gates spent with
Jeffrey Epstein that they're all
connected through prince Andrew who's
connected through the royal family who
you can even see Glenn Maxwell and
Jeffrey Epstein are sitting in a cabin
that is like the most exclusive Royal
cabin that there is some Swiss Chalet or
something I don't know if you guys are
familiar with the photo that I'm talking
about oh yes you know and so the fact
that they would have access to the Queen
the you know they were hanging out with
Kevin Spacey Kevin Spacey was in the
queen's chair it's like this is like a
form of drama like what we're doing
right now is Gossip just on a level of
people we don't know personally see this
is this is different this is Criminal
Predators happening with Bill Clinton on
the Lolita Express 26 times
on the flight log that we know of with
no secret service this guy is the top
guy and we know that if you look at his
pattern of behavior what he did in the
Oval Office with Monica Lewinsky shows
you that he's willing to do stuff
because he is a sexual deviant and does
not follow the rules so if you think
that he's going to Jeffrey Epstein's
Island addiction she could service yeah
and that's what I'm saying no secret
service to go to St James Island just to
drink some uh uh you know whatever pina
coladas I'm sorry but you're dreaming
but when I say drama I'm talking about
doing a show where you're like did you
see that guy when he was drinking that
that beer wow what a what a dumbass
versus that guy's on a plane with
children to a private island they're
trafficking you made a good point that
it's criminal talking about criminal
criminal Behavior especially criminal
Behavior it's not just that it's the
government it's how your life is being
affected it's how they're they're
harming your children it's how they're
destroying your property it's eminent
domain it's a violation of the
Constitution these things will make it
the these things are evil people
criminal people these are politicians
lying cheating stealing has a direct
impact on the survivability of humanity
and the future of this country and our
culture and the world and then the other
thing is I saw a guy walk outside and he
was eating a bucket of ice cream what an
idiot yeah I think it's like a fractal
and let me explain that like drama is
good in small doses gossip is good in
small doses because you need to know
who's crazy if someone around here is
going to go nuts everyone needs to know
so we can make sure that guy's not here
um and that's why communities would
gossip so you can learn about yourself
through gossip through watching other
people deal with drama and that's good
but if it overtakes you the conversation
that's bad thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time